support the only
ongoing China okay the engagement is a
fact and we're seeing that China will be
engaged by your many European Industries
companies uh European leaders that's
that's a that's a fact the question is
with what message do you engage if you
engage China from the position of
weakness where you declare your
dependence and strategic dependence on
on China
that is that puts us in a very
disadvantaged position and we've been in
that position with with Russia for a
very long time and therefore I would
very much like to see Europe
you know being a proud shaper of world
geopolitics when it comes to very
important events and for that we need
yes we need to engage but also from the
position of
I would call it strength but it could be
a economic strength it could be the
strength that comes out from from the
risking that the president of the
commission is suggesting and we are
actually very much supportable
some elements in in the document which
we'll be discussing uh do not show that
strength so we would like to see more of
it
yeah
a lot of trouble with China and you have
supported the Taiwan
previously and you were erased from
importing exporting to China how is this
situation
between Lithuania and China
how much support do you get from your
colleagues in the union or
enough
enough so um I think that the famous
case showed that China is is ready and
willing to use economic coercion as a
political tool or even one might call a
weapon against the countries
that its foreign policy is not in line
so to say with with Chinese version of
of foreign policy the way they would
like to see it so definitely I think it
taught us very valuable lesson all of us
globally that there have been cases
before you know case of Norway a case of
Australia a case of South Korea
but probably we would not have not
understood until lithuania's case that
how far are they willing to go
and this is an Awakening understanding
that we are up against a strategic rival
that would use any instrument that it
has in its uh Arsenal you know the to
pressure countries to do its to its will
and I think the Awakening then allows us
to form a stronger a stronger strategy
so we received assistance we received
political political help and I mean we
we found our way out so we are we are
back as an exporting country to China
we're able to export I think that China
does not like a position that actually
it put itself in you know cornering uh
they thought that they will Corner
Lithuania into into a position but it's
actually worked out differently so they
wanted to get away from it
um and so it's it's definitely better
but again it's an it has been an
Awakening call and I'm glad that now
here we're actually discussing a new
reality a different reality that also
Lithuania was part of uh part of
creating
that uh that's always when there's the
same message that we are not with you uh
till it's needed but we're with you till
the victory
uh so we are more specific more clear
about about our strategic goals how we
are supporting the supporting Ukraine
how soon can they be paid to
Ukraine in your mind he should be paid
as soon as the decision is uh is made
and the solution is found unfortunately
we're still in the process of finding
the other solution as to how to uh
legally uh use the funds for Ukrainian
reconstruction actually some of the
decisions might be made in Lithuania
quite quite soon we are looking into the
West because there are possibilities of
certain bilateral uh I mean unilateral
decisions uh within within European
framework that means that Lithuanian
government has a right to use certain
Frozen funds of the funds that are
received out of uh blocked Russian
Russian funding to use it for a
Ukrainian needs I would not say
reconstruction because that's not a lot
of uh funding and maybe that could be
used as an example for others
everyone here says it appears that
decoupling is not an option do you agree
with that
you know it's a it's a rhetorical phrase
uh I'm I don't hear any advocate for the
coupling
uh probably the point that I'm making is
that
before
uh February
I have not heard anyone talking about
the coupling from Russia and here we are
so honestly I think maybe not in the
public maybe not everybody but at least
somebody has to
devise a possibility
that the coupling might happen not
because we wished it like with Russia
not because we wilted but because the
situation for example in Taiwan Straits
has been changed by force therefore
Europe needed to react and the reaction
would lead to some sort of a of a
decoupling so I'm hopeful
that there are people who are putting
their best Minds a lot of time into this
and thinking about this really really
how could that happen so definitely not
advocating just suggesting that in the
especially in the informal meetings like
this that's a good topic for discussion
thank you so much
thank you
thank you yes okay you can start
speaking whenever you like okay hello
great to be here
well it's very important meeting very
important two very important topics
first discussion on the continuous
support for Ukraine against the Russian
aggression how do we assess the
situation what can be done in order to
make sure that we are safe that this
existential threat is the third in
Poland zoo is quite clear Russia must be
deceited it's otherwise if Russia is
allowed to reap any fruits from this
criminal aggression it will only
encourage it to attack again and even
worse it will encourage other
wrongdoers other troublemakers to follow
suit if you want to stop this Russia
must be defeated it's very good that we
have managed to support Ukraine very
extensively for the last 50 modes of 50
months almost they are putting the
support to work right now we are very
hopeful it will be successful and this
support must continue we will be talking
how to finance it there is a way to do
it the money has been frozen Russian
assets Russian reserves we should find a
way to put this money for good use it
should not be European taxpayers that
Finance it should be Russia that pays
for this aggression and there are two
tools to do it political will this need
and I hope to discuss this today with
with my fellow ministers the other
community well there's always there are
always degrees to Unity Unity is
achievable it's not always at the
beginning but the last 15 months proved
that EU can have some different
perspectives here and there but in the
end we are able to afford to compromise
even if it's difficult even if it's
sometimes harsh words are being spoken
but we are here meeting in the
conditions that allow for very honest
sincere discussions looking very much
forward to this another topic that we'll
be discussing is our position towards EU
China policy how are we going to uh
assess the current situation what are we
doing how are we going to recalibrate
the the EU position how are we going to
be United uh vis-a-vis this very
important Global partner also very
important Global rival we have to admit
that there is a revelry we shouldn't
turn the Blind Eye to the global
situation but there are ways to
cooperate in a positive way with China
keeping in mind that we should remain
United as the West together not just
Europe not just European Union but the
transatlantic relations in this regard
are very important the global situation
we shouldn't be treating something that
happens in the Taiwan Strait for example
in East China see us some distant remote
issue that doesn't concern us it does
concern us because it can affect
international trade and can affect very
intensively how European consumers are
affected for example to various crisis
resulting from disrupted Supply chains
we already have observed that a few
years ago when it comes to
pharmaceutical markets we can see now
that when it comes to electronics to raw
materials to to Red earth materials
there will be an ongoing issue how to do
it so that Europe is not subjected to
some form of dependence as we as Europe
were to some extent dependent on Russian
energy sources we shouldn't make
ourselves dependent on any other country
for that matter in the future so we
should work to find a way to be a
partner not to be a client
[Music]
well we should ensure that any uh
attempts at breaking briefing
international law deterioration of
security globally Global is always met
with uh definitive designs answer the
deterrence is always put to place in any
attempts at the stabilizing the
situation would be met with unequivocal
responses there should be a question
about it any position that would
encourage somebody I'm not I'm not
pointing fingers against anyone but if
any stakeholder would like to create uh
tensions to destabilize situation this
affects Europe we have to admit this we
have to embrace this and we have to be
ready to react if need be that's cool
you want to have more better relation
with China according to this well we
want to have as good relations with
China and as with any other countries on
a partner based mechanism or on a
partnership or
taking into account the differences
between us obviously there are these
differences we are fully aware of it but
at the same time encouraging all to act
in a responsible and predictable way I'm
sure that we are able to do it if we are
united as Europe and I think this Unity
is achievable even though some might uh
be having some some plans to act
unilaterally here and there I think
together as Europe who are stronger as
Europe and as a translation Community
because U.S is also a very important
partner here so you mentioned deterrence
when it comes to China what are the
means in your opinion to deter China oh
I don't want to get into any specific
measures at this point because right now
we are talking we are and we are willing
to to keep a very good relations with
China with many other partners that are
also very important in the in the in the
Pacific region but it's very important
is to uh declare
unequivocally that any attempts at this
stability the destabilizing situation
would be met with European answer
European and transatlantic cancer this
is very important to keep it as I think
we can draw some conclusions from our
approach to Russia if we would have been
more decisive before let's say 2021 if
the the approach the willingness to be
stronger would be then
better coordinated if this voice of
Europe would be more uh visible and less
equivocal than perhaps Russia would have
been the third we know that many errors
have been made when it comes to EU
Russia policy in the past we shouldn't
repeat these errors vis-a-vis any other
major buttons
I don't want to point the fingers
against any other country I hope that we
will today have a very sincere
discussion it will be presenting our
positions from Poland's perspective it's
very important that there is no uh
equal distance between Europe and the US
and between Europe and China Europe and
the US have been transatlantic Partners
building stability building peace
building Prosperity based on the same
values for decades this have proved to
be an effective way to ensure peace in
Europe While most part of Europe after
second world war this is a successful
policy this is a successful Alliance we
should continue this and I think if we
are united with the US with Canada with
other partners that are like-minded to
us then we will be also able to have
better relations together with China and
with other countries that might be uh
thinking differently right now
sign up we will be discussing uh many
topics today depending on the specific
ideas there is a very extensive document
presented by the European external
Action Service it's very good fruit for
very good food for thoughts and we will
be discussing it we will see what will
be achieved I hope that whatever will be
achieved will be achieved in the spirit
of European Union Minister do you
believe
rule in bringing peace to Ukraine well
according to the current plan perhaps
not so much but if there is because this
plan is not entirely in aligned with
international law
Ukraine peace proposal The 10-point
Proposal is is much more favorable much
more in line with the European uh
approach and all the international law
because it entails first of all the
respect for international recognized
borders this is absolutely conditioned I
think the nobody should should question
this and I hope though but it's not that
we can completely reject uh Chinese or
any other country that would like to be
involved would like to be helpful any
idea to help achieve peace not just
quick peace but also stable permanent
peace is welcome but it always has to be
in line with international law so not
optimistic well optimistic in a much
more optimistic than it would have been
let's say if there wouldn't be any
progress in the last 15 months but we
were able to make to make a lot of
progress and I hope that so it will
still continue that we will still be
able to to support Ukrainian Victory
against this Russian imperialistic war
Vladimir Putin's current
position in Russia
his position is still quite strong
unfortunately still that dictator the
president but Russian state is obviously
uh in the worst and worse shape we could
have observed that during the ninth May
parade how small it was compared to the
previous years obviously this is just
symbolic this is this does it doesn't uh
entail all the information about the
Russian state but we have been also
indicating that if we are as Europe as
transatlantic Community
persistent and consistent enough if we
continue to support Russia's weaker than
us and Russia will inevitably inevitably
be getting weaker if we are stronger on
sanctions if we are stronger on
permanent confiscation of Russian
reserves and assets then we will be able
to make this in Russian imperialism lose
this is the this is the goal that we
have because there is no other way to
ensure permanent peace in Europe
so inside the country
inside the
Rock what are the consequences of the
current situation the more that they
call military operation the the fact
that the president cannot travel
anywhere more or less without risking
being
arrested yeah well look this is a
situation that we can compare to the
Soviet Union back in the 80s and Soviet
Union it was far stronger in the 80s
than Russia is today many uh
politicians or Academia members many
people that were commenting on
international relations back then were
predicting that Soviet Union will
continue until mid 20th 21st century and
it collapsed very quickly just after
Afghanistan while they entered
Afghanistan in 1980 and in 1987 then
they collapsed 97 1979 and then they
collapsed in the 90s Russia is weaker
State than a Soviet Russia was they
still are fueled by this illusion of
restoring the old Soviet Empire but
these days are long gone the sooner they
understand it the better for them if
they don't understand it we need to make
them understand because otherwise they
will keep attacking us and I think as if
we look at how Russia looks like how
Russian Russian army looks like this is
possible obviously it doesn't mean that
this war has already won that this war
is already going to end successfully
there's still a lot of working a lot of
support for Ukraine is needed but I'm
sure that if we don't stop halfway we
can achieve this result
thank you very much
foreign
shot
again
foreign
[Music]
thank you
whatever
[Music]
shops
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
button
s
thank you
uh
[Music]
um
you know
my channel
the child
foreign
[Music]
thank you
I'll speak in Greek
[Music]
s is
foreign
scandal
castana
[Music]
is
response
can you say something nice about me
foreign
[Music]
thank you
so much
[Music]
foreign
checkers
[Music]
the time
going on
[Music]
thank you
it would be much easier
please in the great spot welcome to
Sweden welcome very happy to be Sweden
in nice weather I look Spain
expectations we have for the meeting
today well today meeting has two points
Russia aggression against Ukraine
and recalibrating our relationship with
China
on the first issue
clear that we have to continue
supporting Ukraine and we have to do
that in the Long Haul
not just providing ammunition for to
tomorrow fight
but looking in the median term
and preparing and multi-annual support
to Ukraine Ukraine has to be sure that
we will support it not just on the
everyday battle in the war
but in the long haul
and Russia has to understand Putin has
to understand that we will not fall
so we stopped waiting for us
to get tired will not
this is about Ukraine to support the
landscape peace plan
and to make proposals in order to
look for accountability
what kind of a Tribunal
I personally and many members say it
will support the idea of
internationalized Tribunal
we have to look for a solution that
comes quickly we need a solution
practically implementable
and ready to use
China will be the big issue today
the ministers have received a paper
written by the high representative
services in order to
Define a position of the European Union
toward China
this is foreign policy
and for the policy is a matter of the
council
we will prepare the discussion of the
leaders at the European Union Council by
the end of June
and on this paper we recalibrate our
position toward China
from the three bunch of people China
being a partner
it is a partner
we exchange with China 2.7 billion euros
a day
so forget about the coupling
China is a competitor
certainly it's economic growth it's a
technological capacity is a competitor
we have other competitors not only China
but China is an important competitor not
only a supplier of cheap Goods
and third our systems of a political and
economic systems are different
completely different we are multi-party
democracy they are a single party
we are market economy
Chinese economies being driven by the
state
so we are very different
and in the world we are Rivals because
we present our models to the rest of the
world
but we have to engage with China I think
the key word is engaging
and reducing dependencies
engaging and competing
both things the word engaging has a lot
of meanings
it is impossible to try to solve the
most important Global challenges without
the strong engagement with China China
is burning more coal that the rest of
the world together so forget about
solving the climate change without the
strong engagement with China
this is going to be the discussion of
the member states the
paper is a very calibrated paper in
order to
put
in evidence the fact that we need more
united
Euro has to be more united
if we want to be relevant
on the emergency of China's a great
power
the European member states have to be
more united
and act in accordance with a common
policy and it is the task of the Foreign
Affairs ministers to build it
Taiwan is part of the Strategic
challenges that we have with China
which I know we have a problem of values
values as I said before different
systems human rights different
approaches
we have a problem of economic
competition and Economic Security
and we have an issue of strategic
security
an honest strategic security there are
two main issues Taiwan
and the war of Russia against Ukraine
on Taiwan we are
on the same
place that we have been always Taiwan
matters
We are following a China policy
and we want the escalation in the zone
what's happening today one matters a lot
for us
well this is what diplomacy does
the first thing to say is that we cannot
have a normal relation with China
if China doesn't use
the strong influence that China has on
Russia in order to stop this war
the attitude of China towards the war in
Ukraine is the second strategic security
issue that we will discuss today
[Music]
was announced on assumptions for Chinese
Trump circumventing the the EU sanctions
there is no decision taken
and the treaty doesn't talk about
sanctions talks about restrictive
measures
these are proposals for restrictive
measures of the triangle trade between
Europe China and Russia
there is no decision taken yet not even
started the discussion the member states
will have to discuss that on the
following days
and finally the country will adopt a
decision
in Israel and Palestine now there have
been statements from your side has there
been any attempts by the European Union
to actually intervene to facilitate a
ceasefire or you've been only supporting
Egyptian attempts or uh the Arab
ministers attempts we are ready to do
whatever
necessary and useful
I've been talking with my Egyptian
colleague the Emirates
we are not launching and it will be an
initiative they are already
enough initiative what we have to do is
to support the ones who are in the lead
the ones who are in the latest the
African Union and the Arab countries
how concerning is that and doesn't mean
that the European Outreach to emerging
economies is not working
it certainly needs more engagement
one of the things that we have to
discuss is how we reach out more and
better
with the hedging countries
countries who vote in the United Nations
against invasion
but afterwards they are not as strongly
as we would like to be against invasion
and there are countries who doesn't
condemn the invasion in the United
Nations
so yes we have to engage more with the
people who are not exactly in the same
position than us and this is part of the
paper about South Africa I only have a
fresh news
the official position is complaining
about Russian interference in the
elections are you concerned as well
the European Parliament has been voting
about it
there is a resolution of the European
Parliament that talks a lot about the
Russian interferences in elections even
in the country I know West so yes
certainly it's a matter of concern
sanctions
foreign
[Music]
whoa okay
good morning
something
video
[Music]
foreign
and you
know
[Music]
thank you
anyways
[Music]
foreign
Italian
operations
[Music]
the governor
there is a reflection within the
government on this thank you so
hello
I'm perfect
so I will make three messages what we
are going to put on the table today
first is that we must point we must
support Ukraine until Ukraine will win
the war politically and also we must do
the European Union decision about the
one million rounds ammunition as soon as
possible Estonian government has decided
to do our part already so we hope that
the other governments are following as
well the promise because ukrainians they
need this support the second is that we
must discuss
we must give the very clear message to
ukrainians for the next steps to joining
them to Nato we must say it loudly and
clearly during the business Summit
and the third very important topic is
that Putin and his puppets must be
brought
to trial
under the international
tribunal this is very important topic
um
I'm satisfied with the 11th package
Estonia has put many offers in as well
and and it is also important that
karamurza
process these people who are connected
with karamuza process they will be
sanctioned and also the third countries
Transportation through the Russia this
is there so I'm satisfied
uh
[Music]
we very clearly announced and this is
well known that Estonia is independent
country since 1918 and we were under the
Soviet occupation 50 years I was amazed
at the join US ambassador made this kind
of statement but I was very happy
I think that this support can very
strongly form the Democratic World
Beijing has announced as well that that
has not been any change of the China
policy but I take it as a test of our
unity and and we are united on that
value-based topics
this is this is a this is a topic what
we must discuss all together as as a
European Union
opposition is that European Union must
have the common foreign policy towards
China as well but any sanctions which
are lowering Russian war machine are
useful but this is a pretty
strong political decision but we discuss
of course China trying to play uh
bilateral games as well all the
economical relations with China are also
political ones China using they're using
uh economical uh relations as political
ones but if we want to be successful
then we must act together as United as a
European Union so this is our clear
message
if there will be a peace and this piece
must be made under the president
zelensky and ukrainian's plan this is
clear and if you're talking about the
security guarantees then NATO is one
clear and strong current for that so any
kind of other peace plans which are not
approved or not supported by President
zelenski and ukrainians they are not the
peace plans
I have no more details about that really
but any kind of uh
intervention to elections are not alive
[Music]
I have no Vex about this I'm ready to
comment later so thank you very much
good morning and I'm very happy to
be here in in Stockholm in Sweden and
two participate in the very first
Council where we are going to have a
discussion about China and Russia
when it comes to China we do believe
that it's about time for the EU to have
more united much more efficient common
policy because we are seeing that from
time to time we have some different
voices and I think that there is a time
to have much more coherent approach when
it comes to the human rights when it
comes to the security situation and also
trade relations and of course I will be
trying to push for more sanctions on
Russia I think that the 11th package is
of course step forward but they still
are not doing enough when it comes to
putting real pressure
well I think that we still need to
Target financial sector more
thank you
it is a great pleasure for me to be here
in um in Stockholm for this gimnic
meeting on the most important topic for
us which is uh countering the effects of
the Russian war against Ukraine I will
reiterate Romania strong support for
enhancing and extending uh as long as it
takes the support for Ukraine in order
to win this war and to defeat Russia
strategically from that perspective it
is extremely important that we continue
the multi-dimensional support for
Ukraine the pressure on Russia and the
Outreach towards what we now call the
global south from that perspective the
tomorrow ministerial of indo-pacific
together with EU ministers will will
play a very important role I'm glad that
I will co- moderate the session on
security for tomorrow's uh Forum at the
same time I will express our support for
the 11th package of sanctions it is
extremely important that this practice
should be adopted as soon as possible
and be a very strong one at the same
time I will welcome the progress towards
financing through the European peace
facility the military support of the
European Union for Ukraine last but not
least extremely important is to find a
solution for the tribunal the crime of
aggression Romania is part of the core
group of states which is working on this
matter we need to find a very solid
legal basis for that but to start the
work of this tribunal as soon as
possible
not also very importantly also not last
but very importantly it is the support
for the EU work session of of Ukraine of
the Republic of Moldova and Georgia it
is important that by the end of this
year we have a decision for Ukraine and
Moldova to start the accession
negotiations for the European Union well
Moldova I will ask for the support of my
colleagues for the Swift listing of the
first person's under the new sanctions
regime which was created
recently upon my proposal which I have
made in February against persons who are
acting towards destabilizing the
Republic of Moldova or acting against
the Constitutional order of the Republic
of Moldova as you know on the 21st of
April during the previous Foreign
Affairs Council we have reached a
political agreement for the creation of
this sanctions regime now that the
sanctions regime was created which I
think it was the fastest process of
creation of a sanctions regime within
the European union now it is important
to move very fast in order to list the
first persons who are responsible for
destabilizing the country on EU China
relations very very important to
recalibrate our strategic approach and
at the same time I think it's very
important I will underline this to get
rid of the dependence on China in
strategic sectors and also to coordinate
with the United States because we are
like-minded with the United States on
this issues and I think it is very
important to build
strategic transatlantic resilience as
far as China is concerned thank you so
much
yes please
as far as Romania is concerned I do not
see any kind of risk I think it's very
important that we coordinate to the
United States as far as China is
concerned of course the European Union
has its own views and interests but we
are the same community of values and
security with the United States that's
for sure our transatlantic relationship
is the first of all Partnerships the EU
has and I think uh well we need to
coordinate with the United States we
also need to coordinate with other
like-minded partners like UK and other
partners around the globe because all
these matters are of great importance
for the European Union I wouldn't use
the word uh strategic autonomy I think I
think resilience strategic transatlantic
resilience is perhaps the best formula
to encapsulate this coordination and
this this joint action of for your EU
and the United States
well I think it's premature to discuss
about this we are here to discuss the
main Avenues the main strategic ways I
think a discussion on the Strategic
economic Outlook of the relationship
between EU and China is needed but we
will not do it today today we will
discuss the main political and strategic
aspects so thank you so much
good morning first of all I'd like to
thank the Swedish presidency for hosting
this important meeting the Russian
aggression in Ukraine unfortunately
Antares it's
440 third day and therefore may need to
stay as United resolved and strong as
under day one
uh given the circumstances intuition on
the ground are a continuing Financial
humanitarian and Military
assistance to Ukraine remains crucial
at the war in Ukraine has serious Global
consequences including food insecurity
and this is why we need we need to stay
engaged with certain countries to help
them to overcome these challenges as
Croatia Croatia knows very well
uh landmine contamination will be the
biggest recovery challenge for Ukraine
and this is why we're organizing uh the
mining conference in Croatia together
with Ukraine later this year of course
we need and we need and we we stay ready
to uh to share our expertise to share
our experiences in the other areas
Fields such as psychological
Rehabilitation
uh peaceful integration of occupied
territories and prosecution of war
crimes Etc thank you very much
good morning everyone very good to see
you fantastic to be here in Stockholm
here in Sweden I think Sweden had a
fantastic and is still having a
fantastic presidency we're very very
grateful for our Swedish friends how
they are contributing to our European
future main topic here today is of
course discussing the horrible War
Russia continues to wage in in Ukraine
and I would like to reiterate what I've
said before and that is we will continue
to stay and stand with Ukraine because
we are in this for the long run and this
conflicts this war might unfortunately
take much longer and and might really
ask more from us and test our
perseverance and we will not give in we
will continue to stand with Ukraine
because this is about Ukraine but it is
also about Safety and Security on the
European continent and it is in effect a
litmus test for our credibility
and today I'll call again on all member
states to continue with sanctions
continue with listings and also do more
together to make sure our sanctions and
listings are not being circumvented
um and next to that of course we will
continue to push for more weapons
deliveries more humanitarian AIDS and
eventually helping out with rebuilding
the country
secondly we also talk about the EU and
China relationships we will continue to
engage but as you are aware there are
also various reasons for concern and
that we will discuss as well thank you
the reports I don't have any specific
Intel on on the case itself so I can
only talk about it in general terms but
in general terms I would really call on
everyone across the globe to refrain
from sending weapons to an aggressor the
U.N Charter is crystal clear about
sovereignty and that means that all
should be on the side of international
law all should be all should be on the
side of the U.N Charter and should
refrain from helping the aggressor
thank you
so we'll do this
well what's what we've said before is
that there are multiple layer studies
relationship and clearly we we want to
continue to engage with China on on
Safety and Security on on business on
climate change which is a topic which
affects the whole wide world and yet at
the same time they're also various
reasons for concern uh clearly human
rights domestic interference in an
adults but also in in other countries
cyber security and of course you know we
also continue to call on our uh on our
Chinese Partners
to articulate to Russia that they have
to stop this war
what I've said before is that you know
we always have to
um uh be active and and respond to the
events as they unfold and and I've said
in the Netherlands before is that what
we seek is partnership but we cannot be
naive and we also have to be explicit
that for example a domestic interference
is something we will never allow
foreign
[Music]
I think it is helpful to talk about this
in in in in general terms uh and and
then it is clear to everyone across the
globe how to respond to the way the the
European Union sees this and for me it
is crystal clear that we have to
continue with sanctions to get to
continue with listings and have to
prevent sanctions and listing
circumvention because otherwise it it
doesn't make sense and therefore I think
we have to be more explicit to make sure
we we work against workarounds we
prevent uh countries and companies from
uh from doing this
you know what I've said before in public
is that we call on all parties
to refrain from indiscriminate attacks
and that it is of tremendous importance
for all the people involved involved to
sit down and make sure we we finally
start working on a two-states solution
there is no alternative
foreign
[Music]
governments do need to take the lead and
and need to paint how they uh how they
see this what is needed and what is
expected of in this case companies and
that is also why Netherlands has been
pushing before
for putting sanctions uh circumvention
higher on the agenda and therefore I'm
also glad we're discussing that here
today
[Music]
I've always said that that for for us
for the Netherlands there are no taboos
and we are you know open to look into
any conventional weapon system uh if
that would help on the battlefield but
of course you know this is something we
we don't do in our isolation this is
something we always do together with our
partners uh in Europe and in North
America to see what is viable What It
Takes what is appropriate
um and and and that is the way we will
continue to uh to to to to engage
um and and specific systems particularly
those who have not yet been
deployed we we don't tend to discuss
upfront in public
thank you
foreign
[Music]
for us there are no taboos and and that
we we do need to look into what is
needed to win the war
um and and we're not upfront excluding
any type of of weapon systems
and yet and that is that is something
I've been saying all the time
um this is not something we do in
isolation you do this with Partners in
Europe and and in North America
um uh and and that will take careful
calibration our position will will
continue to be that you know one we
provide Ukraine with weapons we have
ourselves to uh we help them by
basically buying stuff which we did
before with the d72 together with the
Americans and the Czech Republic and
three we will continue to build
coalitions of countries
um to make sure together we can do more
as we did on the Panzer howitzers Emma
broadly on on tanks together with their
friends from Germany uh and many others
yeah
you know it is as as always with the
with Coalition building it you typically
typically don't help the process by uh
by giving intermediary updates even
though I see the the juice of the story
on that so sorry for that
thank you thank you
foreign
conflicted
um
foreign
at this
absolutely
um foreign
thank you
hello it's a very important gimney of
course we are discussing Russia
developments there hopefully the issue
of the 11th sanctioned packages ongoing
we will of course discuss Ukraine as
well president zelinski just visited
Finland and we had a meeting with our
president and the prime ministers from
Nordic countries and and discussed about
the Ukrainian peace plan proposed by
Ukraine and that's of course all our
support and then we will discuss about
the China topic it's an important
discussion and of course
we also need to plan a strategy for the
risking with China while we are
maintaining the engagement with China
China is very important partner and we
think for example climate is globally
exactly
well that's very important discussion
and I I think that when China has also
appeared with their own peace plan for
Ukraine and Russia it's very important
that we get engaged with China and and
try to get China to report the Ukrainian
peace plan in these circumstances I
think president zelinski has expressed
very clearly those issues that are
needed for a peace plan and we should
actually not only with China but also
African continent with Latin America get
more engaged and and explain what the
violation of the U.N principles means
not only in Europe but worldwide in the
United States
foreign
[Music]
speaking about the engagement that we
engage also with the African countries I
myself had a trip to Kenya and Somalia
and earlier this year to Senegal to
discuss these topics how president Dean
is the trust visited South Africa also
to continue the debate with South
African key African Partners I think
it's it's very important that we explain
why it's important globally to support
Ukraine and so that we can maintain the
key principles of the U.N Charter how
should Europe respond if indeed South
Africa providing weapons to Russia but
of course the first issue is that we we
have to really look what has happened
what has exactly happened on those
issues and and then of course raise our
voice because we are supporting Ukraine
unanimously from European union and
maintain our support Finland has now
just delivered 15th military package to
Ukraine and of course we hope that the
Ukraine can not only resist but claim a
victory in this fight and Russia should
withdraw from the occupied areas
from China to providing support Russia
what about sanctions on the global South
uh countries like South Africa
well I think it's very important that we
start even more effectively engaging
with the with the key Partners on this
issue and of course we also have to show
our interest on other conflicts like on
the Africa We are following very close
to what's happening in Sudan and I think
Europe shouldn't be one-sided in a way
that we only concentrate what's
happening now during the Russell's
attack against Ukraine but we also show
solidarity in those cases that are
important to other continents like the
conflict in Surah thank you hello
I I want to just have a very short
statement that today we will have a
significant input on discussion on China
which has a rising power poses certain
challenges opportunities and we as EU
need to find a clarify way how to how to
approach that so that will be my uh my
uh my mission here today and of course
we need to continue our discussion on
Russian imperialism and the worry new
crime so yeah
we need to be very actively looking for
ways how to have a geopolitical impact
as as Europe as the EU there's a
multiple practical ways uh and uh we are
fully supporting all necessary measures
to happen to do so
time to discuss it publicly but
generally we need to be very actively
looking for ways how to approach that
I need more information on it I have you
know just a newspaper uh articles on
that but definitely we need to be very
strict to our policies so let's
investigate into that and then possibly
react yeah
this is up to debate but you know this
is how it is right now uh my statement
LED uh to the fact that there is no
significant activity happening so
it is it is what it is it is not causing
uh there are no significant activities
happening so so we are in this state of
limbo I would say
[Music]
I don't think that this is about
repercussions look at three body
countries which left without any kind of
repercussions so it is it is definitely
not about that
thank you very much
but one question please okay because I'm
I'm taking the time
uh well so first of all it's a good step
here that we have this a discussion that
would allow us to form a strategic
stance what I would like is that the
distance would be that the messages that
we are sending to China would come from
the position of strength and we also
have instruments that we also have
Arrangements
that that we possess that could be used
as a leverage on changing China's
position on one case or another so it's
not just a position of weakness it's not
just position of dependence
or risk assessment that would not allow
us to you know to to to do the risk from
from China so that would be my message
here to the colleagues that that the
paper in principle is not bad that is
being that was proposed by by Mr Burrell
and others in in the commission it's a
good food for thought paper I would say
but then again my main message is that
in some cases it it might appear that we
are still on the same
um Railway
as as we've been with with Russia and I
suggest that we learn from the mistakes
that we had with Russia and do not
repeat
same as to others don't help Russia
I'm
any any I mean
look the point is that we are worried
about any country supporting Russia
so all the messages appear they have to
be checked they have to be proven we
have to have facts in hand that's that's
always the case but you've seen our
reaction when it came to Iran uh you
know Lithuania was you know very quick
to react we we participated in the
sanctioned packages we we provided our
knowledge and capacity as much as we
could in order to send a message not
just to run but to anybody we will be
tough
in in any case when certain certain
information appears that the country is
assisting Russia against its war in
Ukraine thank you so much
um foreign
foreign
buffer
occupation information
foreign
[Music]
this is
Target the room this time for something
in the top of the start so this is uh
you understood
it is
foreign
[Music]
einstead
that's the afternoon
foreign
thank you
the minor board shaft Elizabeth
foreign
um
technology
foreign
[Music]
other
income
uh results
Christine
uh
[Music]
at least
foreign
military
intelligence
[Music]
foreign